hi there I'm going to depart from my
normal format today and I'm gonna be a
little more personal and I'm gonna talk
about the joys of being a polyglot in
the 21st century the age of
globalization and I'm doing this because
I had to go for an ultrasound the other
day and after that around 11:30 quarter
to twelve I went to this little cafe and
it advertised itself as home made this
home made dad and sure enough the coffee
was delicious and I had a vegetable
quiche which which was delicious and so
I'm thinking myself Wow you know here
are these people who are putting all of
their care and love into making this
wonderful little cafe and delicious food
they actually serve me and I thought all
of the different people who work for me
or us okay who are providing services
like even the the ultrasound you know I
had an appointment I was phone two days
before I got a SMS message that I had to
confirm I get there 10 minutes before my
appointed time 1120 1120 I'm ushered in
ultrasound and by the way the technician
looked Chinese so I asked her if she
spoke Chinese and she said yes and so he
spoke a little in Cantonese just my
jollies maybe she didn't like that I
don't know maybe I shouldn't do that
at any rate then I go to this cafe and
the girl serving me my coffee I can
detect a little accent and I asked where
she's from and she's from the Czech
Republic
so I speak to her a little bit in Czech
and that causes a lot of chuckles and
her sidekick
is I asked her what languages she speaks
and she says she speaks Farsi and so I
said I'm gonna learn that language once
I learn the writing system first for
Arabic and she said that she can't read
the writing system so she's obviously
she was obviously born here but speaks
Farsi because of her parents so and
that's a bit you know the kind of
society that Vancouver has become while
on my way to the coffee shop I saw this
big burly RCMP mounted policeman he is
obviously Punjabi and he was speaking to
his buddy who looked
also to be a Punjabi neither of them had
a turban but you know you can tell that
they're from that part of India
originally maybe one two generations but
they're all speaking English they're all
Canadian and at any rate so I'm sitting
in this cafe and I'm thinking of all the
services you know as someone living in
the 21st century like you read that in
the Middle Ages people just heaved
garbage out the window and it all
collected and it was washed away by the
rain or something
whereas now the community here picks up
my compost once a week so all of our
kitchen scraps we collect them they're
gone I don't have to worry about rats in
the garden from my compost pile
obviously recyclables are collected so
the amount of garbage I have is once
every two weeks is not that much so
that's happening for me these are people
who work for me even the health system
my doctor I just go see her whenever I
want to I can get in within four or five
days if it's an emergency sooner she
sets up maybe a lab test I go there it's
free
I look up the results on the web she
sees the results I communicate with her
about the results via email she answers
me the same evening all of this is free
yeah I mean these people are working for
me even you know the products that we
use this iPhone that I'm using somebody
made it for me for others as well so we
have a level of service you know Greek
learning for example I want to find some
good podcast for Greek I go to iTunes
itunes find on itunes Greek you can
change the flag at the bottom will take
you to whatever country you want and see
what what's popular in those countries
so I go to Greece I find the most
popular podcast there are two language
pause Greek language podcasts there one
is on politics one is on history but
iTunes won't let me buy it in the Greek
iTunes store I have to buy it in the
iTunes Canada store which of course
doesn't have the Greek podcast however I
get the name of those podcasts I go to
their websites and I download the
podcast so now I've got lots of good
listening material but of course I don't
understand very much of it yet so I go
on to an outsourcing website at work and
I find someone who
a reasonable rate will transcribe these
for me and I got my first one this
morning so now I'm able to import that
in the link and I pulled the the audio
file in and now I've got this lesson and
we'll have more and more and more and I
will be learning about Greek history and
Greek politics reading and listening
these people are working for me yeah for
some you pay for some you don't pay I
don't mind paying we all have to work
for a living so people who provide a
service obviously should be compensated
for their effort but it's just that you
have available to you such a range of
services and not only like in my
community here at a very local level the
people who collect my compost and
recyclables and garbage and by our
health system which I pay for in taxes
but which I'm not aware of you know
these are people who are helping me yeah
at some level I paid somewhere but I'm
not aware of it all the time you know I
have my municipal taxes my provincial
taxes my federal taxes but I'm being
looked after like I pay for my iPhone I
pay I pay for having the transcriptions
made but at least these are services
that are available to me you know a
hundred years ago fifty years ago these
kinds of services were not available so
I just think sometimes it's useful to
sit back and say wow you know we really
do have it good in the 21st century and
our people are gonna say yeah and global
warming and this is another I personally
believe that we will solve the issues of
global warming through technology we're
already seeing a dramatic increase in
the the sales of electrical electric
cars and so forth and so on and despite
the horrible natural disasters man-made
disasters Wars I mean these have existed
since the beginning of time I believe
that we you know first of all there is
less war destruction wanton destruction
you know of lives and famine than always
kind of stuff
less than there was 150 200 years ago so
we're slowly heading in the right
direction however human beings being
human being human beings we continue to
see these tragic scenes around the world
however I mean I'm limited in my ability
to influence those things so I like to
focus on things around me I follow
events elsewhere if I could influence
them I would but I can't so I preferred
it to at least be aware of how lucky I
am and how many different kinds of
services of people who are working doing
their jobs come back and benefit me and
particularly benefit me as a polyglot
because I am able to talk to people
through Skype I'm able to find learning
resources on a final note I did try to
contact a school in Crete to see if I
were to take private lessons for a week
what that would cost and its really very
expensive so I think I will invest my
money in transcripts because if I get a
10-minute transcript of a podcast
interview and even ten of those maybe
not 10 but five of them I could get an
hour's worth of Greek interviews with
transcripts that I can study on link for
less than it would cost me for one hour
of Greek lessons at this school in Crete
so I'm not going there so we get to pick
and choose our services but at least
this range of service is available to us
and not even louis xiv at the height of
his majesty had as many and as the same
range of services available to him so i
consider myself to be very lucky bit of
a rant here i'm not sure what i was
trying to say but i'm be curious to see
what people have to say bye for now
[Music]